So with all that in mind, let's jump into Unreal and start creating a socket in one
of our skeletal meshes.
So sockets is essentially just a point attached to a bone.
And the great thing about sockets is they then move with that bone so you can attach
different components maybe at runtime.
You can add essentially any extra mesh to that bone and it has multiple purposes.
So if you think about this car example, it's great for designing an attached location such
as a door handle or a mirror or something essentially that wasn't part of the rig that
came into Unreal.
So let's go ahead and create a new socket just to show you what that process would be
like.
So I've just got a car here and I'll hit CTRL and B in my content browser to find that
skeletal mesh in the browser.
So if I can open up the individual asset but just to show you going through the skeletal
mesh window which we were speaking about in the PowerPoint, if I went over to the skeleton,
I can see all of my bones here.
So again, I could have gone if I just drag and drop these windows just so you can see
my browser, I could have gone through the skeleton here.
But if you're going through this skeletal mesh and you're not sure where the skeleton
is located, that's how to get there.
So I went through the mesh and then clicked on skeleton which opened this window.
So you can essentially add a socket anywhere.
If you say, let's go for the hood maybe.
So over on the hood, say for example, we were attaching a windscreen wiper.
So this windscreen wiper isn't there by default.
Maybe we want to attach a windscreen wiper to the hood.
So we can just right click and add a socket.
And then it creates a socket name based on the bone name.
And so hood underscore body socket, that's a nice enough naming convention.
I'm happy with that.
I don't need to rename it.
Now with the socket, the good thing about the socket in Unreal is that if I press space
bar and then space bar again, I'm just toggling through my widget here.
I can actually move this into a different location than what the bone would be.
So if I wanted this socket in a different location, for example, that's an easy way
to do that.
And so it's like offset from the bone which is here.
And that will move.
So say this bone was animated on the windscreen wiper, whatever the relative offset of this
socket was, that would follow the bone's orientation as well.
And just a little tip when you get into blueprints, if you are attaching a mesh to a socket or
something like this, you'd need to get the socket name.
So a lot of the time you could misspell the socket and the socket name needs to be specific
inside a blueprint.
So you can either hit F2 or you can right click and rename socket.
And when that box opens, I just hit control C. And then when you're inside a blueprint,
you can just hit control V. That's copy and paste on the keyboard.
And that will essentially just paste in the socket name.
I like to do that just to make sure I know that the naming convention is all correct
and working.
That's essentially how to add a socket to a skeleton in Unreal.